comment éviter les coups de soleil alors
on va se mettre d'accord tout de suite
je vous le dis tout de beau le concept
de préparer sa peau au soleil c'est du
pain dans les cabines de bronzage vous
êtes exposé à des UV artificielles qui
colore votre peau mais qui ne stimule
pas la production de mélanine donc ça ne
vous protège pas ça peut même être
dangereux parce que même avec les
dernières réglementations les médecins
estiment que les UV artificiels sont
responsables de cancer de la peau du
côté des autobronzants et des
compléments alimentaires divers et
variés pareil ça vous permet d'avoir le
teint à aller un petit peu avant de vous
exposer au soleil mais ça ne vous
protège pas du tout seul moyen de se
protéger des coups de soleil c'est
d'éviter de s'exposer à une trop grande
quantité du V surtout au début notamment
entre midi et 16h puisque c'est là
qu'elle est la plus importante donc un
couvrez-vous de laisser votre pouce
reposer un peu évitez de rester trop
longtemps au soleil et 3 mettez de la
crème